what are Narco Cults what's the
relationship between you kind of
mentioned religion a little bit yeah
what's the relationship between
religious culture and drug culture first
off Mexico is one of the most Catholic
countries on the planet if not the most
Catholic country on the planet not only
that it is a country that has a root in
a spirituality through its in ethnic
culture
that other other parts of the world got
most of that taken away and or
suppressed or killed or taken away
um when the Spanish came to Mexico they
were a product of a recently liberated
group of people they just got done being
invaded by the Moors basically
and they brought with them the message
the version of Guadalupe and Hernan
cortes's vision of that version of that
was a lady holding a crystal scepter
baby Jesus and standing on a crescent
moon that's what that's what he brought
with him to the Americas
and uh when the conquest happened you
know a lot of people say the Spanish
came and conquested the mech the the the
Aztec empire
the enemies of the Aztec Allied
themselves with the Spanish and they
took them now that's what happened and
then the rest was famine and sickness
that's what killed most of them
they realized that it was going to be
hard to suppress some of the spiritual
practices in Mexico so they decided to
meld them with Catholic iconography
so you see these uh this cult to uh to
not scene which is like a fertility
variant of a mother goddess and not that
culture and they turned her into La
Vegan de Guadalupe which is the icon
that a lot of Mexicans venerate as the
La Vega and the virgin
um but in her she conceals cultural
elements from the past she has a black
sash across her stomach which means
she's pregnant something common in the
Aztec uh culture and the mexica culture
she's standing on a chair that has Eagle
wings that is a war god
that's the symbol of the war god down
there she has stars on her which is a
veil of certain stars that are related
to some of the spiritual practices from
before
basically they hid these things in in
that in that setting now you skip
forward
you know hundreds of years
and you start seeing things like uh
malverde who was a bandit that lived in
Sinaloa way back in the day he would Rob
Rich Farmers that would go through the
uh the countryside
one time he was almost caught and he was
shot and injured and he was wanted by
the government so he told one of his
friends to
tell them where he was and to give the
money the reward money to the
townspeople
so we did that
the he was hung from a tree and the the
order was not to bury him just to let
his body rot and his body rotted away
until it fell under the ground bones
and each of the townspeople would go
over and put a rock on top of his corpse
until it became a pile of rocks and then
he started granting miracles
so again this whole aspect of these
criminals become insights
uh and also a middle finger from the
downward local populace to the uh the
church in a way because there's not a
recognized saint but he has a an altar
and people venerate that
then you have
cartels that have a spiritual practice
or spirituality behind what they do
which is part of their culture but is
also like a tool they use to
ingratiate themselves with the local
populace or the or the population around
them uh their icon icons of power and
sometimes of
almost a symbol of rebellion uh you see
El Chapo's son when he was arrested had
a Santo ninocha on his chest which is a
it's a holy kid of a torture
the Spanish Legend during the Morris
Conquest uh they said that a statue of
that Saint would go around and feed some
of the hungry you know that was a legend
and he's a he's a saint of the
persecuted so the fact that when he was
arrested he was you see him with that
wearing wearing that and then he was
liberated is a miracle in and of itself
so it's proof that that works you see
that that was you can find one of those
scapularios anywhere in Mexico that was
the most highly sold one
um
so you see them utilizing some of these
aspects uh in in their own belief system
to as a similar as I kind of iconography
basically for some of the things they do
then you go into some of the other
aspects of it that are out there like
Santa Muerte which is actually a faith
that I grew up in
Mexico has a weird relationship to death
we have parties at the cemetery on Day
of the Dead and we I just went through
one you know recently this is uh
November November the 2nd
um so we celebrate our dead and we
celebrate death in a way that I don't
think a lot of cultures out there do
it's a joyful occasion it is a
celebration yeah my eight-year-old put
two beers on an altar one for my mom one
for my brother
she bought a Snickers bar for my mom and
a a bag of pops for my brother
flower petals and marigolds and pictures
of them on an altar that's amazing what
kind of beer
Roja for my mother because he's you know
she was Hardcore and they got the light
from my brother you know he was a more
of a endurance drinker
um and it's also for me
yeah the relationship to death down
there is different so there's an icon in
Mexico it's actually one of the fastest
growing
alternative spiritual practices in
Mexico
and not not only in Mexico but here in
the US I've been to Santa muerta temples
across the country I found one in
Connecticut out of all places
how I grew up with it or I thought is uh
we would we my family was on
guadalupanas we were we were catholic
and we venerated the version of
Guadalupe specifically the icon of the
version of Guadalupe
but every now and then there are winks
and nods to a skeletal Saint in in in
family practices and even when I went to
work uh
the the guy the older guys that were I
was working with would tell me like hey
we gotta go ask uh ask for protection
so they would drive me over to the
church and I thought it was going to the
cathedral and then we made a left turn
and it wasn't the cathedral it was the
Market next to the cathedral in Tijuana
and in the little corner there was a big
uh Santa Muerte Reaper Refugee and
then I knew why I had to bring a bottle
of tequila I was like why am I bringing
a bottle tequila to the church
it was for her death la muerte
it was partly hazing
and also they did believe that they were
basically imbued with
the being agents of death in a way so it
was like a cultural thing as well
something that they they wore on them as
not only protection but it's also like a
like a samurai would wear this death
iconography on them or how
uh the Maori would do uh Haka dances you
know to some of these guys in their kind
of warrior culture that they were
growing up with or trying to imbue on us
the young guys
uh they would um take us there and they
wouldn't view us with iconography of
Santa Marta to be like a psychological
thing so that gives you strength and
meaning in the face of struggle like in
the in the face of difficulties in life
I think uh you know if you're closeness
to death and having a relationship to
death in the form of a symbolic uh
representation of it like uh Santa Marta
or Nikon like that
makes it not as scary I guess or not not
only that but it's also something that
the other side
the enemy the cartels groups they would
venerate it as well so when they would
see it on you it was almost debilitating
to them they were like oh are you guys
cops are you guys why why are you
wearing that
uh so it was an aspect of that to it uh
a
momentumori type thing where you'll
remember death you know type thing
there's some aspect in which you don't
want to mess with the person who
meditates on death there was some of
that yeah
there was a saying I think they probably
took it from a movie or something like
that but I don't know where they got it
uh mayor may I earn your need and be
your Wrath
oh man it's a good line they would say
that to the Statue of la Santa you know
and another thing people it's not a
cartel specific Saint though it's like
everybody like at all levels from the
lady that sells tortillas
to the um
to the cops to the military there's some
people in the military that venerated uh
there's a there's a very specific symbol
of how this is like a weird relationship
in specifically in Santa Marta in Mexico
there's a there's a shrine outside of
Tijuana right across the uh
Tijuana
and there was a big Santa Muerte uh
altar there like on the roadside
and my former boss lisaola ordered that
thing destroyed
so the the he boarded a truck to destroy
it it was a famous thing
and it was rebuilt the next night and I
know for a fact that some of the people
that rebuilt that were some of the same
guys that you know were destroying it
oh man that's pretty symbolic so it's
just it's not something that can be
killed it's a part of the the spirit of
the people it keeps getting destroyed by
Ultra Christian groups or Catholic
groups and it keeps getting rebuilt
personally for me as a
you know it's I don't believe that
there's a Reaper skeleton in the sky
protecting me
but I do believe in the aspect of an
ending you know and how it's important
to you know the ending is important in
all things and death should be present
in life and if it's not then you're
delusional about things
so the to you it's a mechanism to
meditate on death once again yeah and
you know having uh my daughter who's
eight
uh be who it has a
benevolent thing you know she's a kid
and she sees a skeleton that represents
death and Jesus does it's like
I think uh
in a way Mexicans have taken some of
those aspects be it Day of the Dead some
of these practices related to some
occultism aspects around uh you know
Saint Judas you know sankudas
Saint Judas is the the patron state of
lost causes
and it's one of the most venerated
Saints in Mexico you know you know Jesus
is probably the fourth or fifth you
prayed which is pretty funny ridiculous
but the reason why and this is something
I heard from somebody that uh was
actually we found him with a gun and on
his gun he had a Saint Judas effigy
and uh he said oh like why is San Judas
and he's like well he's the last Saint
you prayed to
what do you mean well on the list of
saints you pray to he's the last one
because when you pray to Judas you might
get the other Judas on the line yeah
that's the last one you pray to that's
why he's like the Lost Cause of saying
how I remember like
even how we try and bribe or like
maneuver our way into human in
spirituality it's spiritual practices
yeah you know such a fascinating culture
that's unlike anything else
and it's right next door
and it's here too again uh I I found an
altar in Connecticut which is pretty
fascinating there's one in Arizona
again it's one of the fastest growing
spiritual practices in in the in not
only in the US but like across there's
uh somebody from Russia reached out
there's an altar out there and there's a
group of people praying to Santa Marta
and I've been posting and writing a lot
about it recently just from my own
experience and some of the stuff that I
gathered for myself and
all the way out there
you know people are fascinated by some
of those aspects